originally everyone thought social
security would take care of us that's
probably not gonna be the case it used
to be that if you wanted to invest in a
venture capital fund you had to have a
million dollars or more peter thiel
famously invested 500 000 in facebook
turned it into a billion dollars most
people say yeah but i'm not peter steele
and i don't have 500 000 in my
retirement account but that's not the
point you can take 500 and achieve the
same return einstein referred to
compound returns as the eighth wonder of
the world that's what you get with
retirement accounts and if we can all
take advantage of that bang let's do it
all right guys bang bang i've got eric
here with me eric i thought a great
place to start would be kind of a primer
on retirement accounts i think lots of
people have heard of retirement accounts
uh they may even have one but they might
not understand how they actually work so
like what is the purpose of a retirement
account and why are they so advantageous
for the everyday person
well
loaded questions
so thanks for starting easy um you know
i i think
uh most people know that uh a lot of
folks have just um brokerage accounts
where they can invest in in stocks and
bonds some may be more surprised to
understand that there are actually more
people with uh retirement accounts than
uh non-retirement brokerage accounts so
give or take 150 million
retirement accounts across
across the population
and
the the the retirement account was
created
this is like it's not a surprise right
uh the the logic logic holds up the
retirement account was created to give
each of us an opportunity to save in a
tax advantage way
such that when we get to retirement we
actually have some savings to fall back
on right so originally everyone thought
social security would take care uh would
take care of us
um i think
not again unfortunately not a surprise
that's probably not gonna be the case
since by 2035 i think it is we're sort
of on a path for social security being
run dry
and
uh there are two really important parts
to the tax advantage nature of
retirement accounts
one is where you invest on a or you um
contribute funds on on a pre-tax basis
and get to invest on a tax deferred
basis that means you don't pay tax uh at
you know sort of across time and you
only pay tax at the end when you start
to take distributions the other way and
this is and that's referred to as a
traditional ira the other ira is
referred to as a roth ira
with the roth ira you're putting money
in on an after-tax basis you also get to
um invest tax-free
over time but then when you take those
distributions because you paid the tax
up front you get to withdrawal uh on on
a tax-free basis and so
um for those who can afford to
contribute to roth iras that is a huge
huge advantage um and and everyone
should do so over a longer period of
time as they can
but the traditional ira is still a great
way
to put money away
invest on a tax-free basis as you go
and then only pay tax
upon distribution and of course i think
you and i talked about this once before
einstein referred to compound returns as
the eighth wonder of the world um that's
what you get with retirement accounts
and if we can all take advantage of that
then bang let's do it and so when you
think about uh kind of these uh accounts
they essentially are used as an
incentive to get people to think long
term right you lock up the money for uh
a predetermined amount of time and the
government will give you tax benefits uh
for doing so what are the types of
assets that people normally are putting
in there are they putting in cash are
they contributing other types of assets
like what goes in and then we can talk
about what they're actually doing once
the value is in that account
so um historically retirement accounts
they've never been restricted by the way
to public stocks and bonds but
historically
uh it was only easy to invest in public
stocks and bonds now the irs
for um uh
let's just call it accounting purposes
and for
um
clarity
says that you can only contribute cash
to a retirement account so you can't
take um ibm stock
from your
uh non-retirement brokerage account and
contribute it to your retirement account
you first have to
uh liquidate take the cash
and and then make the contribution
um
now
yeah uh for for those who don't know uh
i'm the ceo of a company called alto
and alto
is a both a custodian and a transaction
execution platform that makes it easy
and affordable for folks to invest their
retirement savings in non-publicly
traded uh securities so that can include
private equity venture capital real
estate crypto assets
um private credit etc and so
um the the drafters of retirement
account language all the way back to
when erisa was created in the early
1970s
accounted for the fact that we weren't
going to be limited to just publicly
traded stocks and bonds so really
that the
the now short answer to my long-winded
question is that almost any type of
asset can reside within a retirement
account but in terms of what goes in and
what comes out
for the most part it's cash there are
exceptions to that rule on the way out
but it's complicated
and so when you think about these types
of assets obviously we mentioned the
compound uh growth is a huge advantage
uh the stocks in bonds some of it was an
access play which is easier to buy those
inside uh but i'm assuming private
equity venture capital other types of
kind of long duration type investments
uh as it has become easier to access
those within retirement accounts they
kind of line up with the incentives of
these retirement accounts is that a fair
statement it's a hundred percent fair uh
not just fair but accurate so
um one of the you're referring to
duration matching right so you're taking
dollars that are meant to be saved uh
and invested over a long period of time
and you're investing them in assets
which are going to actually take a long
period of time for uh in order for you
to to achieve liquidity liquidity is
when
um an an asset is sold uh and uh you
receive cash in return so for example i
invested in venture capital funds on day
one you know a hundred dollars goes in
and hopefully uh 10 years later or
somewhere between 7 and 12 years let's
say
10 comes out
um
and
that that of course is
advantageous to
a retirement account investor one
because that money that money comes back
to the record retirement account on a
tax-free basis
uh but two i couldn't touch that money
anyway right not not until i retire and
so
these are exactly the dollars one should
be using to make long-term investments
the other big thing that's changed over
the last now uh five to seven years
is technology so
you know it used to be that if you
wanted to invest in a venture capital
fund you had to have
uh a million dollars or more
uh in today's world and with various um
investment platform partners that that
also works with you can invest as little
as a thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars or a hundred thousand dollars or
a million dollars it doesn't matter
and you know
um
peter thiel famously invested five
hundred thousand dollars in facebook
turned it into a billion dollars most
people say yeah but i'm not peter steele
and i don't have you know five hundred
thousand dollars in my retirement
account but that's not the point
the point is actually that you can take
five hundred dollars or five thousand
dollars and achieve the same return
and that's the point
and so when you think about these long
duration uh type assets it's almost
exactly opposite of if you were to put
dollars in let's say you were you know
25 30 35 even 40 years old and leave it
in there for call it 20 to 40 years uh
the dollar has historically uh been
devalued quite a bit and so the idea of
saving in your retirement account is
actually a little kind of weird because
it's not saving what you're trying to do
is get dollars in and then invest inside
of the retirement account right
yeah so uh unfortunately i think
everybody's getting smarter with respect
to the effects of inflation uh in in
today's economic environment but you're
100 correct if you take dollars
uh and and just put them in a checking
account or savings account and um
you know they they earn very little of
any interest
over that 20 to 40 year period of time
when it when you take that dollar out
it's actually been devalued
right so the dollar is no longer worth
the dollar um and and that is uh
sometimes
i should say the dollar that comes out
20 to 40 years later isn't worth the
dollar that went in 20 to 40 years
earlier
and um
which speaks to the fact that you know
what we need to
uh we need to to make investments and we
need to take the risk reward
into consideration as we build our
portfolio one of the things that we like
to preach at alto
is portfolio diversification so it's not
that public stocks and bonds and public
markets are bad or good
they play a role they're just not the
be-all end-all and so how do you get
portfolio diversification that allows
you to reduce the overall volatility of
your portfolio and increase the
long-term returns um and and that
happens with alternative assets and so
especially
everybody who has a brokerage account
today uh whether it's a retirement
account or otherwise is looking at their
statement and they're seeing a
significant decline you know 18 to 22
percent
if you look at your alternative asset
balance for most people nothing has
happened and it's not that
uh those assets haven't gone down in
value they may have gone down some some
may have gone up but you're only
repricing
when uh when a transaction happens
whether a private company raises money
uh or sells itself but otherwise you you
can't wake up
and hurt yourself with uh alternative
assets because the liquidity is not not
just there for you to access
whereas in the public markets and and we
all know that 99 of us are terrible
traders you know the market goes down we
wake up we sell the market goes up we
wake up we buy it's the exact opposite
of what we should be doing and you can't
do that with alternative assets and so
um it it is not only a good portfolio
hedge it's a good hedge against human
nature
and so when you all think about building
out this product one of the things
that's fascinating to me is you
obviously offer the kind of stocks and
bonds access you you've pushed further
and further into alternatives uh and
then you also now offer uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrency access as well where does
that idea come from it are you seeing
that like kind of customer demand or
market demand and you're saying hey we
gotta go build a solution here is it
something that you all predict and then
kind of customers move into that area
because now it's available how does that
work
so
um you know because crypto is still so
young in its uh in his life
it it
most of the traditional brokerage firms
um
haven't made
the the crypto asset
uh portfolio
available to its client base and so and
i don't know if you remember this way
back in 2016
you and i were talking about doing a
crypto you know at the time bitcoin
mining
operation together and so
i had um
you know bitcoin got onto my radar
screen sort of 2013 2014
uh around 2016 2017
when i was on the board of the tva
uh
to me this felt like a no-brainer that
the tva who has an endless amount of
energy at basically zero marginal cost
ought to be in the crypto mining
business
um
uh the the answer you know i was like 30
years younger than most of the other
board members and so when i brought up
bitcoin
i got a lot of blank stares and looks on
my face and i just couldn't get the
board there so uh
then i actually i called you
and and we were looking at doing a uh
crypto mining facility together um and
for various reasons that didn't quite
work out but the the the point is that
crypto had been on my radar for a long
period of time and when i recognized
that the other that the traditional
brokerage firms
fidelity schwab td etc weren't allowing
folks to invest in crypto
which at the time was bitcoin and a
little bit of theorem i said you know
what we need to do this and so over um
over about two years i was able to build
a a relationship with coinbase
and eventually partner with them such
that
when
our client comes to the alto platform to
invest in
uh crypto assets the transaction
execution while performed over the alto
platform actually takes place at the
coinbase exchange and so that that's the
way it works for us and our clients
and so today when somebody comes in how
much money could they put into uh an
account how much can they actually
invest and then what are the assets that
they could buy in kind of the crypto
ecosystem
so
um you know what's really interesting if
if you go and you ask the average
uh
consumer is is is there more savings in
like
pension funds or 401ks or or iras
most people will say 401ks but the fact
of the matter is that actually iras have
surpassed 401ks in terms of total
dollars saved
and they're continuing to grow at a
faster rate than 401k so reason being
is that we all now stay at a job for a
shorter shorter period of time than we
used to
and when you leave that job and go to a
new employer you have the opportunity to
roll your old 401k into an ira
also the gig economy where people don't
have access to 401ks but only iras has
been a major
growth accelerator for the for the ira
basket if you will
so on an annual basis
those of us though
i can't say those of us
those who are uh
50 or younger can contribute uh six
thousand dollars a year um those who are
older than 50 like me get a
quote-unquote catch-up uh
allowance and it's either 7 000 or 7 500
a year so
um
that amount uh you can contribute every
year to to an ira there are some
restrictions
excuse me and you should probably
consult a tax advisor if you're in a
high income bracket but for the most
part that's that's true and accurate uh
with without other characteristics
involved um but
what's not captured in that is that
ability to roll old iras or old 401ks
into a single new ira if if that's what
you want to do
and so if you look at what
um the average account size at alto
represents it's we you know we're north
of a billion dollars uh probably 1.2
billion over
30 000 client accounts so i think if we
do the math that's give or take 40 000
on average but uh i don't think that
tells the whole story i i think we'll
see that we have we we have uh client
accounts as low as you know 500 and as
high as 2 million or more dollars
and as you start to see uh people come
in and use these products what are the
risks like what are the downsides
potentially of using a retirement
account or or investing in these types
of assets in a retirement account
you can still lose your money
right like it's
you know
and and by the way people used to think
that the argument when we were starting
alto right was you know people aren't
smart enough and uh there's too much
risk and and and by the way they were
talking about that in the context of a
of a public market run that we hadn't
seen in a hell of a long time right and
so people thought that the public
markets could only go in one direction
i think the tune has changed a little
bit um with respect to that that
uh you know the the public markets are
not risk-free
uh that there is downside uh
unfortunately we we've seen a lot of
that but it has accelerated the
conversation that alternatives really
are gonna play a role
going forward right because historically
you had to be a ultra high net worth or
high net worth individual
or professional institutional investor
to participate in these markets and and
you know thanks to technology
uh you no longer have to have that
million-dollar uh blank check to
participate you can you can participate
at much more
um
well i'd like to say you can participate
at any economic scale that works for you
yeah what's uh what was fascinating to
me is if you look at some of the public
pension funds we've seen them push
further and further into alternatives
even in some cases take on leverage
where they previously have it and so
obviously they're going out further on
the risk kind of curve they're looking
for uh certain types of yield that maybe
they couldn't get previously and so
there's not really a big difference
between someone investing in their
retirement account looking for better
returns looking to combat inflation
looking for a kind of higher yield than
the quote-unquote professionals who work
at these pension funds
they have very similar goals right in
some way they're just simply investing
the retirement funds of the pensioneers
uh in a pooled fund versus you doing it
individually inside of your own account
yeah i couldn't say it better than you
just did right which is um more people
actually have access to alternatives
than than they know it's just because
some professional institutional
uh
manager is investing on on behalf of on
their behalf in their retirement account
and you know when i was first looking at
this in in early 2016 by this i mean
the opportunity to to create this
platform that would allow individuals to
easily invest in alternative assets
using their retirement account
that
there were a few different things that
stuck out one was we've got 30 plus
trillion dollars sitting in retirement
accounts
the next was that less than two percent
of the time was invested in alternative
assets and i compared that number to
what we see
uh on an after tax basis for high net
worth and ultra high net worth
individuals and that's going to be
anywhere from 10 to 25
and then when you put the institutional
money managers in the mix that's going
to go from 25 to
you know yale famously invested as much
as 80 of its endowment
in alternative assets and what i what i
sort of that
rightly or wrongly that what i concluded
was that um this process of investing in
alternative assets was too complicated
uh too time-consuming and too expensive
and so if we could solve for those three
things essentially what turbotax did for
self-filing
uh if we could if we could do that same
thing for alternative ira investing well
then we could really help a lot of
people and change the theta retirement
in this country so that's what that's
what we're trying to do when you think
about uh bitcoin cryptocurrency
specifically i know there's a lot of
nuance around these assets what should
people know about alto ira's kind of
crypto offering and some of those
nuances whether it's specific
functionality fees anything like that
yeah so um
we make available to our customer
anything that's currently available on
coinbase well there there's some
geographic restrictions involved with
that but if it's unavailable if it's
available on coinbase it's about it's
available to you at uh
at alto now
i don't think you'd be surprised to
learn that the majority of the holdings
of our client base uh reside in bitcoin
ethereum is second solana is third
cardano's fourth right like a and then
there's a long tail
um and we don't tell you what to invest
in we don't tell you what not to invest
in we make it available and you know as
you're um
want to say
uh you know you got to do your homework
right and um
as we were just talking about a second
ago
that there's risk reward in every
investment and
and another thing that that i i think
we've discovered over the past couple of
months in um in the in in the crypto
environment is that the rules of finance
don't cease to exist
right you get you can't get something
for nothing
and um
you know the the more
uh the more crazy the return seems the
the greater the risk you're taking on
shocking ideas that seem to have been
never just decades ago
maybe even centuries ago depending on
who you ask um when you think of the
product today what's kind of the pitch
to folks like why should they come and
use alto ira and specifically uh the
bitcoin and crypto uh kind of
functionality yeah it's really easy
that's why you know um it's it's easy
and and it's affordable and it's meant
to really unlock access to these asset
categories for for all people for all
retail investors
and
uh you know like you i i believe um in
the future of crypto and where it's
headed and the and the role that it will
play i can't tell you what the winners
and losers are gonna be uh long term but
but it's gonna be here and it's not
going away and we should all have the
opportunity to to benefit from the
sector uh so long as you do your
homework and
and and
make make your investments you know
wisely you're not you're not going to
bat a hundred percent uh nobody does
where that there will be losses but
there will also be wins and and the key
is and this is no different than private
equity and venture capital by the way
the key is to have the winds
you know far far out pace
the losses
uh and you know anyway that's my
approach
and when we think about where people can
go where can they find you on the
internet or where can they find out more
about alto if they want to check out the
product
yeah um alto ira.com
a-l-t-o-i-r-a.com so
uh hopeful
hopefully when you go there you the the
website is easily digestible and
understandable and it's easy to sign up
for account and
we we make it as seamless
a process as as is possible to transfer
assets from another
ira account to a new auto ira account
and one thing to keep in mind is you
don't have to transfer the whole thing
you can have a fidelity fidelity account
and you could say you know what i want
to put a thousand dollars or five
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
to work
in in alternative assets and so that's
the amount that i'm gonna transfer over
and that may represent five percent ten
percent twenty percent of your total
portfolio and and the percentage that it
represents and the percentage that
you're comfortable with in terms of risk
reward and
um
your your understanding of the
alternative assets margaret that's up to
you
and when you start to think about uh
kind of
what people should expect you said easy
uh in terms of the service itself and
the product usage and kind of how
quickly they can sign up uh what do you
hope customers say to each other once
they actually use the product
that that that's a great question but by
the way nobody has ever asked me in that
question like in the last five years
nobody's asked me that question and um
so i i hope they tell their friends
right so historically
what we know is that bad news travels by
plane and and good news travels by by
boat and i think
social media has really leveled the
playing field in that regard and that if
you do have a good experience
you can tell everybody about it and one
of the things that we talk about amongst
our team at alto is that at some point
while we may be leading the field today
and and my hope is that we continue to
push boundaries and stay ahead of
competition over the next several years
but at some point table you know all the
technology will be table stakes and what
what ultimately makes the difference is
that client experience and the customer
service
experience and
the fact that we answer a phone and
return an email and allow you to sign up
for
a zoom conversation at the end of the
day it's all about the people um and i
don't think you can decide to do that
three years from now i think you got to
do it today
and so
i i have frequently said that
i will know that we have made it when
whoever the ceo of southwest airlines is
at the time you know shoots me an email
and says how do you make your customers
so happy and that's because i i hold
southwest and very high regard and i
love flying that airline and i think
they just do it right and they do it
with attitude and
um yeah so that's so that's our goal
that's awesome uh eric listen i really
enjoyed talking to you today anyone who
hasn't checked out alto ira i suggest
you go and you do that as well uh and uh
the idea of helping people get bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies assets that
traditionally are thought of as kind of
long-term uh duration assets into a tax
advantaged account
as a pretty uh pretty solid idea i think
and obvious why people would want to do
that so thank you to you and your team
for spending so much time and effort uh
to uh to make that possible for hundreds
of thousands if not millions of people
pom thanks for having us